Kevin Frazier said he would take care of
the danettes then we all we also got
that make up you know yeah you need you
know we had to get them make up the
gleam team sent over a makeup artist and
so we got their makeup so throughout the
segment we'll get them power you know
make sure they don't get crazy with the
dentist DC you got you got them right
you they got they sprayed your head with
something for tea well yeah I'm not sure
what that was there was there some kind
of strong powerful aerosol can oh my god
this is not here it was not hearsay
wasn't paint it wasn't anything for the
COS there is that hair in a can we did
that one said yeah we did not way to go
yeah Paulie Dan the makeup artist has
talked to her and I said can you tell
how long a person's been out of night if
they went out really late she was oh
yeah I could tell by the circles under a
person's eyes you like do that and then
I said how long did the Danites look
like they went on she just it looks like
you guys don't go out at all well right
is too we have to get up early although
I think she may have noticed it's eaten
I did ask what shade gets rid of 12
beers is good don't we take care of that
don't worry about it you know it what's
funny is that I get the whole
Connecticut by because when we were at
the worldwide leader yeah they just
didn't care what you wore and I remember
protesting in I used to pick up my ties
on scott van pelt a desk you had a pilot
eyes and you just go through and you
pick out one and you grabbing us like it
doesn't matter I wore the same jacket
for a week on NBA tonight I just I'd I'm
here I'm gonna wear the same jacket
every night is anybody gonna say
anything to me and no one said a word
they're like great show things are great
I was like do you realize that weren't
the same thing every night dude who
cares there's where's there was like a
community grouping of ties Gary Miller
had this as well where you just walk by
and you just grab it tight and you say
huh yeah I remember somebody did a
baseball tonight and I took the tie that
they were on baseball tonight and use it
on sportscenter like 30 minutes later it
was crazy you could literally wear
anything and and that and there was no
place to change there's no place so i
have like tim hardaway in my cubicle in
his underwear like I walk around the
corner it seems in his underwear getting
dressed for the show I'm like hey ok Tim
good luck hi gosh
do you remember when the NBA changed its
wardrobe policy yes but people think
that's Iverson related and I was told it
was Steve Nash related cuz Nash did not
dress he was clean when he and and you
know his jeans and t-shirts he looked
like he was coming off you know the
beach well if you remember in the heyday
Michael Jordan in the Bulls and those
guys they came in the arena clean oh
yeah I remember the first time Michael
put on headphones and everybody was like
what in the world is happening but it
was from practice it was right in Utah
but people got upset like who does he
think he's like he's tuning out the rest
of the world he's better than everybody
he got criticized for yeah because all
of us would wait at the at the entrance
to the tunnel and then we would
literally do this huge crowd around
Michael and walk in with him and so
Michaels walking and he puts on
headphones we're like what are you
listening to he was listen to something
like easy listening like it was
something off a hidden beach is a young
record label you feels like Jionni or
something like that but it was we just
saw thought it was the craziest thing
that Michael had on headphones but they
used to come dress so Wow every game and
that was the thing but I never
understood why these guys would fight
this that you know Iverson wanted to
wear a throwback jersey and change and a
hat on backwards or a do-rag whatever he
was going to wear but they finally dis
you realize you can showcase something
Westbrook look at Westbrook mentor like
these guys come in to Dwyane Wade they
come in but saying look at look at how
um yeah look at me and also those guys
are a business and they understand that
they're marketing but also I just say
this and i'm not anti Allen I love Allen
Iverson but what I am is that you are
the head of a multimillion-dollar
corporation you just have to keep that
in mind that every day you knew when you
go into that arena there are millions of
dollars i mean guys are making 20 30
million dollars a year that's behind you
that's who you are you represent this
corporation so represent it in a manner
that you can go out and get endorsements
in and be a leader in the community and
you know I know like Charles would say
oh I'm not I'm not a role model yes you
are yes you are in there and every kid
that's watching whether it's my kids or
somebody else they're watching they look
at how you look when you
into that arena he's Kevin Frazier
co-host of Entertainment Tonight kind
enough to join us here again in the man
cave now you cover Hollywood yes is
there somebody who is the equal
personality wise in Hollywood of LeBron
James LeBron James I don't know that
there's a LeBrock because LeBron
understand this he's changed and I think
you all you see that and we see it in
the ventures into Hollywood I mean
you've never seen an athlete who goes
and seeks out Warren Buffett when I saw
him sitting with Warren Buffett when he
said I'm down with Warren Buffett that
changed the way I thought about LeBron
be also the train wreck he was great and
it was wet and I loved watching the
people who don't really follow sports in
Hollywood people don't follow sports I
don't know how to break this to you guys
they don't follow sports I can walk into
work and there'll be one guy in the
corner be like you aren't dan Patrick um
but they don't literally and so they
were like this guy LeBron James he was
really funny but he's so big he's like
he's a big huge basketball player he was
a great actor he has more stuff coming
up and he's branching and producing
stuff what he's doing maverick is great
um they really have put together a
multi-level corporation I don't I don't
know if there are guys like that I mean
Will Smith yes and a lot of what
personality wise where he's
passive-aggressive it you know you know
it's just he has a different personality
yeah there's a little will's way more
direct I mean but that that's the
closest you would get you know would be
Will Smith yeah cuz will is I look at a
guy who does so many things he's
multi-talented he's multi-faceted he can
move in and out of things so easily and
he has command of a situation like
LeBron now has command of the situation
and he can take on all comers will is
that way Will's that guy but do you
under you think you understand whose
steph curry is more or LeBron James what
we understand Steph carry more because
we understand his background better you
know we understand his dad and his mom
and his family and how he grew up um you
know with his dad being an MBA but my
took a movie understand LeBron he might
be cockier than LeBron James on the
court of course well yeah I mean step
staff turns when he shoots a three in
turns around and starts running it's
unbeliev now like
I'm in my living room screaming why is
that why is that okay in basketball if
this was baseball that would be a bat
flip or you'd be staring des basketballs
about style basketball is about style in
my face but they'll be they hold on to
these archaic rules i know you know i
mean think about how many fights there
being basketball if they if people got
upset you showed them up during a play
think about how many fights there would
be and baseball really it's what hurts
baseball is these old archaic rules that
are like you showed me up at the flavor
and the style and all those things
that's what makes the next generation
love the game and baseball players are
playing by rules that were there when
walter johnson pitching you know
Christie Matheson is on the mound and
you know guys are like this is how it's
been since 1899 I was like yeah but in
1905 black people couldn't play baseball
so you gotta change you gotta continue
to evolve would that be like shooting a
set shot in basketball because that's
the way you used to shoot back in the 50
and guys we just run off the court you
know like Bob koozie just ran off the
court he dribble around the clock run
throw the ball up and he'd run off the
court yeah Paulie we got a couple of
notes 1 negative 1 positive which you
want first get me the negative the
negative the little fine ladies from
trunk club have to leave and we have to
give them the clothes back so we got to
start get naked get naked which is a GV
okay the second I'm checking my notes
Kevin Frazier may be the first ever to
time in studio in one week guest in show
history well he earned it yeah you
killed it you killed it on Monday and
you deliver it on Friday ma'am well I
appreciate you guys have me back I just
there in Hollywood and I know anything
here's what's happening Adam saddle is
the only guy in Hollywood can get away
with what he does have you seen what he
wear it's crazy he's the only person in
Hollywood who wear sweats to a premiere
and everybody's like that's just Adam it
is he is who he is like he'll wear old
sneakers and sweats and a crazy jacket
and you're like what in the heck is he
doing and everybody's like that he wore
pants on Monday night to the movie
premiere they were corduroys and he said
I got dressed up Danny it's crazy he
gets away with it no one else in
Hollywood does that so I know that your
role model but don't let it always be
alone no that's not no it's not a Roma
no no no Clooney Clooney Clooney yeah
yeah who
always clean like you see Clooney he's
always clean and he's always so cool
like Clooney reminds me of Jordan you
know how Michael can say no to you and
you're still happy Michael Jordan's the
one guy and all I've ever met who will
tell you know on an interview he'll see
you know back keV what's up man hey and
you're like hey Mike can I talk to you
real quick you know I'm not stopping I'm
not gonna talk to you but it's a brother
and you're like Mike just shouted me out
I'm good but but Jeter and Brady are
good at doing yes to Derek Jeter is
great and Derek Jeter once again another
guy like Clooney so smooth and cool and
Jeter always dressed to the nine yet
he's the captain so when Clooney walks
in a place you're just like Clooney and
he you know he'll look at you like
what's going to have you be so good to
see you know I don't have time to stop I
gotta get in there you're like all right
but you don't shout at me I don't we
don't mind being blown it Oh in order to
give you hey good to see you again how's
your mom do it grade okay yeah see you
soon love hey thank you again for coming
on delivering I want to thank the gleam
team in the trunk club yes hooking these
guys up and look great thank God right
you got to start taking off your clothes
get back here Kevin thanks for joining
us always great and I'll see you guys
next time you come in and next time I'm
Milford um it's a bacon egg and cheese
crisps yeah so I took me a lot of
sandwich man I got a sandwich they're
like dude we got you a sandwich I was
like hey and I get to shoot a jumper all
right all right holy the best the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience